i don't think there's time for a serious
relationship with you i think you're
married to stand up i honestly do thank
you for saying that because now i could
use this as proof when i'm in the
argument
[Laughter]
what a perfect relationship for you to
be with another comedian
but what about a power couple like
colin's got his the scarlet what about
you
in a power couple situation like that
are you jealous at all of of colin's uh
relationship with scarlet no absolutely
not i mean i'm jealous
in the way that like oh i'm happy for
you boy i'm happy that you're happy but
uh not i don't i'm not really into
celebrities as being something that's
it's more like oh you found somebody
that makes sense for you like that's
kind of what's cool do you detect that
his work is suffering now in the writing
room because he is in a relationship and
he's spending too much time with
scarlett johansson i believe he's
suffering a lot longer than that there
was something for them
well i was thinking if you married nikki
glazer for example you would then be
this uh comedy power couple and then you
could go out and do stand-up and
everyone would understand there you go
why married already why can't we just
get coffee first
[Laughter]
do a lot of the cast members try to hook
you up with different people like in
other words this collins hey listen
scarlett's friends with so and so all
the time they do yeah all the time
i would imagine that's exciting i don't
think they believe me when i when i tell
them i want nothing to do with show
business you've never seen a guest house
on saturday night live for example where
you go you know that's an exciting
performer let me go over and say hello
absolutely not
wow why are you so dedicated to this
idea
fame and celebrity is
is like the part you put up with
for what i actually like to do which is
perform you know
so
to almost double down and
and a famous woman who is like
it's so much harder to be a famous woman
than it is to be a famous man just
because of the treatment i mean they
make fun of you for wearing you can't
wear a bikini you can't go to the beach
you can't
you can't have you can't wear sweatpants
like they they trash women
famous women all the time it's brutal
so it's just like and now you've
inherited all of that
now you're not you you know that
publicly say he's not good enough he
should she should be like it's just
the way they treat celebrity
relationships the woman always gets the
worst end of the stick and the guy has
to inherit everything she gets so i just
those those relationships i'm always
like wow that seems like
you gotta really really like a
[ __ ] to invest in that but if
you date a waitress or something oh who
cares if she wears a bikini
yeah but but how does she relate to your
life and the trials and tribulations of
trying to stay on top and show business
you know what i mean it's very difficult
i think that's the the move is somebody
that you've known before that you that
kind of has a handle of that's kind of
seen you grow that's why i say it gets
harder and harder every day that you
that you don't
commit to somebody because it's it's
somebody catching you further into this
mess
of celebrity you know